but do i have the [ __ ] obnoxious
audacity this morning
on a nice little sunday show em drock
it's a nice sunday
i woke up with a chip on my shoulder to
talk about
this audacity this [ __ ] audacity that
so many people have
that they think they that this one
[ __ ] person of eight billion you
i'm talking to you that your judgment
if nfts is a good idea or not or if
collecting marbles show it
or collecting old transformers show it
or [ __ ] some
cup from the 1800s [ __ ] show it i
went on a rant on twitter
to talk about this ridiculousness that
people think the world is
either or instead of and
instead of and you're so addicted with
ore
no this is good and that's not like
collectible watches or smart uh
collectible [ __ ]
sneakers are smart but thundercats
are not jackson pollock good sports
cards bad
sports cars good [ __ ] handbags
who the [ __ ] do you think you are
the biggest mistake i see right now on
everyone's hot takes on nfts
is the culture of no and the culture of
either or
if you dropped an m and an e [ __ ]
post edit this [ __ ] team gary
if you dropped an m and an e at the
beginning and the end of that [ __ ]
terrible word
or and made it more you would actually
live life the biggest issue in life
is that people think it's either or that
their religion is better than someone
else's
the political stance is better than
somebody else's that their product is
better than someone else's
that their content is better your
[ __ ] inability to understand
everybody can get theirs that we can all
[ __ ] co-exist that
nfts can dominate while sports cards and
comics and toys
i'm going to the [ __ ] national this
upcoming week or in two weeks
to chicago and i'm gonna buy a [ __ ] load
and i need a [ __ ] load of cardboard
while i'm also gonna buy nfts on the
blockchain
and very easily in my [ __ ] heart and
in my soul
and in my brain and my [ __ ] athens
essence sorry i'm [ __ ] pumped drock
in my essence
it's very easy for those things to
coexist and the [ __ ] that i'm not
interested in
watches sports cards handbags antiques
from [ __ ] europe
and the other trillion [ __ ] things
including
stick with me now the other things i
don't give a [ __ ] about
investing in like stick with me now real
estate
you know how many [ __ ] i give about
putting my money into real estate
zero meanwhile do i understand that
some people do well almost everybody
that's an icon in real estate
and by sports teams steve like do i
understand it yes but do i have the
[ __ ] obnoxious
audacity to think my [ __ ] one opinion
of not being interested in making
passive income in real estate
is right no i do not this world is an
and
world and every [ __ ] person that
thinks it's an ore world
will continue to [ __ ] lose and cry
and [ __ ] leave hate
because you're [ __ ] sad because you
think the world is limited
when it's [ __ ] not so figure it the
[ __ ] out the world is about and
the world is about more and the more you
put passion into leaving little snide
comments
or thinking you're right over a drink or
it's a fad you said [ __ ] social was a
fad dick
you said tick tock was a fad [ __ ] you
said the internet was a fad
you said you'd never get a [ __ ]
iphone because you love your [ __ ]
blackberry
you [ __ ] no mafia there's no mafia so
many of you
are [ __ ] sucks it [ __ ]
sucks
you